Anyone familiar with the work of
director?
David Cronenberg knows that he has an
intense fascination with bodies,
physical bodies,
bodies transformed or bodies mutilated,
bodies dripping or bodies explode,
so it's no surprise that his film,
eastern promises opens with a focus on
three bodies,
the sliced body of a Chechen gangster,
the wounded expiring body of a pregnant
prostitute,
and the fragile small body of that
woman's infant who is soaked in her
blood.
It will eventually become clear that
these three bodies are connected by the
films narrative.
A point that is made explicit early on
by one character's poor grasp of English
barrier secrets was her body's indeed.
It is a central theme of Cronenberg that
body's only exist within a continuum of
other bodies to which they are connected
and from which they gain meaning.
For Cronenberg,
the body is representative of the
individual,
perhaps even more so than the mind,
despite the fact that we're mental
creatures conceiving of things in
abstraction,
we are irrevocably tied to the physical
organism that's given to us and much of
our anxiety about aging or disease or
deformity is directed toward the body in
eastern promises.
The physical reality of the body is
examined in the context of the equally
physical reality of collective violence,
of which bodies are it's perpetrators
and victims.
A Cronenberg only has a few scenes that
actually show that violence,
I think five in total,
but their presence saturates the rest of
the film and you're lingering memories
of it,
but take the very first scene,
the throat slitting,
the way it's filmed.
You're not allowed any distance from the
action.
You're right,
they're your own neck.
Feels sensitive.
Your own hand feels like it's holding
the knife.
Cronenberg is a genius at placing the
audience in the middle of body on body
clashes like this one.
The violence is literally embodied by
the viewer,
but before I get too far ahead of
myself,
eastern promises tells the story of the
expatriate Russian mafia in London and
the ripples that run through it.
When a midwife played by Naomi Watts
uncovers a diary with potentially
damaging evidence against the family.
Connected to this is the story of
Nikolai played expertly by Viggo
Mortensen,
a driver slash thug who's ruthlessness,
judgment and efficiency propels him up
the ranks of the crime organization.
That organization and the Russian crime
world in general is evidenced on
individual members by tattoos that tell
the story of their lives and their rank,
emphasizing the real bodily relationship
between individuals and the group,
and I have tattoos.
You don't exist as well as a captain.
This body,
this corpse who the audience knows was
professionally processed by Nikolai
earlier in the film,
sets up an interesting contrast because
of that processing.
The police can't identify the
individual,
only that individual's rank and history
of crime,
and here's an example of how
individuality is sacrificed to the
collective.
Most groups and especially those that
use violence as a means organized
themselves around some kind of common
ideal,
some code or traditional escalate God
says,
never speak to anybody about you'll get
sane individuals.
It's often hypothesize,
need a shared code like this to commit
acts of cruelty because in a group those
acts can be attributed to the collective
and it's goals and the individual
doesn't have to face responsibility or
individuality is that I think this makes
for a paradox and the problem or the
paradox is that collectives often ask
people to relinquish individuality,
but the thing that defines individuality
and identity for so many people is their
place within a collective.
More on that in a moment.
The problem is that once a person
sacrifices part of his or her
individuality to the group,
the group can then sacrifice the
individual Tatiana,
the pregnant woman from the beginning of
the film,
who's voiceover diary entries,
hang like a specter over everything that
happens left Russia to find a better
life in the multicultural collective of
London,
but she was absorbed into a vicious
subgroup of that collective that
sacrificed her individuality for its own
ends.
Anna,
the midwife wants to connect with her
Russian heritage,
but she too brings herself within the
orbit of the Mafia.
Escaping.
We're Tatiana could not.
The head of the mafia son played by
Vincent Cassel is genetically linked to
his fucking birthmark,
which means he has to sacrifice his
homosexuality,
his individual truth to an organization
and a culture that rejects such a
lifestyle at the risk of being
ostracized or worse.
It's worth noting,
of course,
that Cronenberg uses this case to
highlight the way men use their bodies
to project masculinity real or fake.
Of course,
the major case study here is that
Nikolai Nikolai sacrifices himself to
the Russian mafia,
made perfectly clear by the way he
prefers his naked body to the group and
the ritual almost eroticize scene in
which he earns the star tattoos almost
immediately after this.
He learns the cost of that sacrifice
when he is betrayed.
This isn't only one of the best scenes
in film history,
beautifully choreographed,
filmed,
but it's the scene that brings all of
Cronenberg's themes to a climax.
This matrix of individual collective
body and violence.
Individuals subsumed in groups like the
Russian mafia or in a strange kind of
crisis.
The group doesn't so much demand the
disillusion of individuality,
but rather the maintenance of
individuality that's always united with
the group's intentions.
It's easy to see how paradoxical that
is.
How can individuals define themselves by
connection to an organization that makes
them interchangeable in the bathhouse
seen,
the Russian mob uses this
interchangeability to betray Nicholi,
letting the Chechens identify him as
someone else by his tattoos.
Of course,
the tattoos or a form of body
manipulation that individuals like
Nicole,
I use to code this paradoxical identity
into reality to make it real.
A Cronenberg and Mortenson have Nikolai
fight naked in order to show that by
joining this group,
it's not only individuality that's made
vulnerable,
but the body itself and when it's
revealed.
Finally,
that Nikolai is actually an undercover
agent.
It's these cuts and bruises that prove
his devotion to another kind of
collective,
the police and realize his identity as a
hero who uses the rules of individuals
and groups to his own advantage.
Cronenberg is a master filmmaker because
he can use the elements of a crime genre
film written by someone else to
interrogate these big themes.
Human beings are individuals in
collectives,
they our minds and bodies,
they operate within ideas where blood is
symbolic,
just a color or a bouquet of roses and
yet live in the physical world where
blood can send you to jail or be the
last thing you ever see.
Among these themes are paradoxes that we
can't resolve,
but our body's exposed the truth that
David Cronenberg wants us to remember
that we are all the victims and the
perpetrators of reality.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
If you liked this video and you want to
see more like it more from the nerd
writer,
you can pledge to my channel by clicking
right here and going to my patrion page
lets people just pledged like a dollar
or $3,
but that really makes this whole channel
possible.
These videos take a long time to make
and you guys are what enables this
channel to keep going.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for that.
I love this movie.
I think this is just a great example of
an amazing director elevating a genre
movie to become something more than that
by,
by the power of his directing,
what he chooses to focus on and the
themes that he laces through it.
So I love Cronenberg.
I might analyze more of his movies.
I don't know,
but this is a fantastic one.
I think I.
let me go Mortenson,
so I will.
I'll see you guys next Wednesday.